تستمر المعارك الضاريه في الشرق الاوكراني
بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه مع التقدم
طفيف لقوات باجنر التي تقاتل الى جانب
الجيش الروسي وفي اخر التطورات وبحسب
مصادر الروسيه تقاتل مجموعه فاجنر الان في
وسط باخمت بدنيتك واصبحت القوات الروسيه
تسيطر على جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه
الى ذلك اشارت المصادر نفسها الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول تسليم المعدات
الى المدينه لكنها تتكبد خسائر فادحه اما
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استهدف 98 وحده مدفعيه تابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مواقع اطلاق النار والقوى
العامله والمعدات في 173 منطقه خلال يوم
واحد كما اكد تدمير مركز الغرب للعمليات
الخاصه في اوكرانيا وفيما اعلنت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه ان الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله سوف
تشهد نشاطا عسكريا لحسم الحرب اكد المتحدث
باسم الكرم لان ان العمليه العسكريه ستبقى
مستمره